we're told that justin runs at a
constant rate traveling 17 kilometers in
two hours
write an equation that shows the
relationship between the distance he
runs d
in kilometers and the time he spends
running h in hours so pause this video
and see if you can work through that on
your own before we do it together
all right now there's several ways to
approach this question one way is to say
look he's running at a constant rate so
his distance is going to be equal to
some constant let's just call that
lowercase k
times the amount of time he spends
running
and the way that we can figure out what
k is is by using the information that
they gave us they tell us right over
here
that when our distance is 17 kilometers
so when our distance is 17 kilometers
that's a situation where he has been
running
for two hours so that is going to be
equal to k
times
two
hours
so what is k going to be pause the video
again and see if you can figure it out
if you didn't figure it out the first
time i asked you to pause the video
alright well there's a bunch of ways to
solve for k but one way is to say let's
just divide both sides by two hours
so if you divide both sides by two hours
you are going to get
that k
is going to be equal to 17 over 2
kilometers per hour which is 17 over 2
is 8.5
8.5
kilometers
per
hour
and so if we go back to the original
question which asks us to
write an equation that shows the
relationship between d and h we can say
that d
is equal to we now know our
proportionality constant it is 8.5
times h
8.5 times h and we're done if we wanted
to write their units we could write d is
equal to 8.5 kilometers per hour times h
which is given in hours